[Music]  when it comes to sweet there's only one  name I've studied the best spin moves  his legendary I raced the fastest in the  world he makes us all let's play I'm  wild but he's on another level that dude  he knows it's all about the Rings when  he turns on the burners good luck  he's just a blur out there what's this  for again what's this for against this  Morgan what's this for again great  question I have no idea but please  McCaffrey go on about how amazing I am  what am i doing you're mine Hedgehog  now that's what I call good cop bad cop  left yourself open Sonic he's almost  here so get ready here we go that was an  illegal left by the way for the crazy  blast let me show you how it's done so  should we get out of here yeah time to  go  incredibly fearless any last words be  strong be strong and mr. Rohit I can't  with that guy adventure of the year  Sonic the Hedgehog but my day good time  [Music]